over the years i've been making videos
lots of people have suggested that i
should see the hallig islands in germany
mostly because of the tiny trains every
few years some media outlet does a story
about how the people who live out on the
islands have their own personal trains
to get them to and from the mainland and
yes i'm going to talk about those
but the story here is way more
interesting than that
although yes the best way to get to some
of the halight islands from the mainland
is on board tiny trains and the railway
staff here are going to let me take a
ride
but there's a bigger question
why is there a tiny railroad here who
builds a railroad instead of just a road
los gates
is
if you're building sea defenses in the
1930s and you need to get a load of
heavy material across a tidal flat well
rail is your most efficient option and
to understand why they need those
defenses we need to take a look at the
bigger picture uh but unfortunately i'm
not allowed to fly a drone here because
this is a wildlife preserve but if you
look at aerial images you can see that
the whole of this area the north german
coast is protected by these barrier
islands this area is the modern sea
hundreds of kilometers of sand bars and
mud flats that act as a natural wave
break and storm defense that's what they
were boosting with the earthworks here
manage these islands correctly you'll
protect all the cities on the mainland
from flooding plus people have lived on
these islands for centuries now they'll
happily take the storm defense for
themselves and the free railroad that
comes with it futuristic not so much
this is
one of the problems with living on
what's basically a bit of sea defense is
that you're going to be the one that
gets flooded these islands go mostly
under water 50 or 60 times a year
usually in winter the local term for it
translates as land under the houses are
up on mounds to protect them and they're
built high enough for now but one of the
reasons that the railway is still in
regular use is that it's still helping
to build the sea defenses
foreign
it seems strange to describe an island
as something that needs to be kept
healthy but yeah that's why the
railway's here yes the locals have their
own trains very rarely if they're
staying on the island tourists can ride
too and it looks quirky and interesting
but the reason behind it is to stop
these islands and eventually the
mainland being flooded by rising seas
you